ladies and gentlemen please welcome Yom
dip on Amir
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now the people a lot of people here yeah
this is gonna be exciting we got the
idea from this from the very first
PlayStation experience by the way where
we fired up until dawn great game sure
you guys are fans and had everyone cheer
and Hooten hollered to decide to decide
what actions we should take but before
we do that we'll do that just a minute
guillaume i wanted to ask what inspired
detroit become human well as you know
you know in 2011 we started to work on
tech demo called cara oh yeah and you
know this Android that is getting builds
and when it's released in 2012 we showed
it as a prototype everyone who was
asking you know what happens to Cara
when she goes out into the world and so
david cage and the team started to work
on you know what happens when she comes
out and so we imagine this world in
about 20 years
when human-like androids a really common
place so they're everywhere
they've taking on actually most jobs of
humans and although they look and speak
and behave like human beings they're
only machines they really add to service
of humans and so in the game you're
going to play as three of these androids
Cara of course Connor and Marcus and
they're each very different models they
are have their own backstory they have
their own place in society and as the
player you will have to make critical
decisions that is going to impact their
fate so you're really going to be in
control of the story and change the way
the story unfolds I love games like this
I love games like this and the great
news is this is playable here this
weekend at PlayStation experience
but I don't want to wait why wait right
I I want it all I want to open my
presents right now so Guillaume take
your position please young will be
playing on ps4 Pro and here's what's
gonna happen is all you early-bird
ticket holders out there you're gonna
help Guillaume make decisions in this
game and you're gonna do that by making
noise
right I don't hear you well so please so
a little bit of context we're playing
this hostage scene which is the very
first scene in the game we're playing as
Connor Connor is a prototype
he's been built to investigate deviant
androids androids that all of a sudden
do something weird and so we're going
into this hostage scene where the house
Android has taken a little girl hostage
and we're going to try and save the girl
[Music]
x4 Sean
okay now I'm in control of the character
I can really move him around the way I
want with the left analog stick with the
right analog stick I can interact so
Connor is very intelligent
try and save the fish on up today today
there's no sound
all right now you need go you can't do
that
[Applause]
[Music]
remember that every action has a
consequence
so at any moment you can hold r2 and you
enter what we call the mind Palace of
the character shows you your objectives
so here for instance I can see that can
talk to captain Allen
captain
my name is car and the Android sent my
sacra life it's firing and everything
that moves it already shot down two of
my men we could easily get it thrown the
edge of a balcony it falls she falls
quick so I can ask him about the demons
name emotional shock doesn't matter I
need information to determine the best
approach first thing you tried
seeing that kids are so I think you deal
with this [ __ ] Android now okay don't
know if we said the right thing here but
okay so as comedy investigator
I have special abilities one of his
abilities off Connor is that you can
analyze evidence and if you find all the
evidence you can then put them together
and you enter into the reconstruct mode
so you can basically reconstruct what
has happened
in a recent past so here for instance
you can see that someone
has taken this wallet here so the
deviant took the father's son
okay so we have unlocked something here
apparently that we may use later in the
game so I'm going to further investigate
this apartment which is actually fairly
large so here I'm sorry
so this is really nothing you have to do
[Applause]
okay now we know the deviance name is
Daniel maybe something that we can use
later on
we are good
so at any moment I can press r2 here and
see you know those little yellow flags
that's an indication of everything
that's interactive in the scene in
certain positions so let's take a look
at this person here
I'm a bad controller that we know now
okay now I can reconstruct and try to
understand what happened with him
it's really part of the game plea to
also play with the camera
try to find clues
this kind of creeping you
okay we found something
I've unlocked the new evidence that I be
able to analyze okay now we understand
probably what happens deviant was going
to be replaced
didn't like it
all right so that is a soft reminder
that time is of the essence
and here again I can reconstruct events
try to understand what happened I can
turn the camera
and now I found a weapon
should I take the weapon
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so now I'm a 78% probability of
success let's go
okay now we need to be quick
[Music]
[Music]
slowly
so we want
[Applause]
shall we have two cups
[Applause]
losing blood don't get him to a hospital
he's going to die
All Humans die attention
didn't matter this one guys now I'm
going to apply a tourniquet
why should I do
[Applause]
drew the line
[Applause]
okay so now we can use what we've done
locked quick
[Applause]
betrayed you nothing
that's good
what should I do which
[Applause]
[Applause]
throw away
I showed you a quick
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'll show you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and I want a car but I'm outside the
city I'll let her go
which
[Music]
[Applause]
I knew you would say that
[Applause]
nice job